I want to know what the [ __ ] is gonna
happen with Conor yeah that's I mean you
and everybody else because be you and
everybody else after this performance
have you set it up to a place where he's
the most terrifying lightweight
contender in the world then you have
Tony Ferguson who's a [ __ ]
who's the interim championship champion
and then you have Connor who who knows
what's gonna happen with him and I think
the UFC is gonna give him a little while
I'm gonna give him some time you know
hey let the holidays pass see what the
[ __ ] happens and they're gonna have to
make some moves but they want to do a
Russia fight yeah and if they want to do
a Russia fight I know a guy I know guy
little sell some [ __ ] tickets in
Russia baby yeah Tony Ferguson Gumby but
never got mad off in Russia
what could use it on Twitter about this
Connors what kind of I skin your pets
and only wearing once that's mighty God
truly truly get on your [ __ ] knees
and beg me otherwise I don't give a
bollocks my whiskey is out this year and
that's diddy bread so he tweeted the the
bear thing and then it was I skin your
pets and I wear him once
oh yeah that was that's was
comparatively witty slaughter your pets
and wear them as coats and only wear
them once but there's a lot of it's good
trash talk I like it have you ever seen
a documentary called a bobby fisher'
against the world nofollow chest there
was a there's a document about blood
fisher called bobby fisher' against a
woman whether or not you're in the chest
you should really really watch it I'm
into Bobby Fischer yeah okay it's called
Bobby Fischer against the world and yeah
he was and anyway they interview one of
his his friends his long friends long
lifelong friends named dr. Anthony Sadie
and their last conversation before Bobby
cut him off he said Bobby if you don't
play chess eventually they'll come a
time where no one will ask you to play
chess
that's the situation is you know you can
keep doing this and tweets but the
reason you're famous is the reason
people you have that what you have
running is because you fight and there
comes a time when like I said the
division with the sport in the division
everybody it'll move past you now
economy have enough money doesn't care
about that but that that's always a risk
you I'm doing you know you're an old
school you know Sugar Ray Robinson tried
to be a dancer entertainer and I've got
old and they went you me want to see you
fight and that's all you're gonna get
paid for now yeah he may not have enough
money that he doesn't care about that
certainly possible but there's no sport
there's no division that won't move past
you eventually and that would be a shame
and he thinks that money
yeah but he's spending like Floyd
Mayweather yeah I mean he's going off if
you go off like that
after why you gonna run out of money
yeah I mean it might be 20 years from
now but you know to see him till 20
years yeah and your window to make
money's yeah this big in professional
sports right
you see yeah I don't know if that's I
don't know if it's sustainable I don't
know if he's got enough money to live
the rest of his life but he certainly
doesn't if he just spends like crazy I
mean he might just go through a phase
and then he might decide to cherry-pick
specific fights to make tremendous
amounts of money and there was some talk
about a Pacquiao fight in boxing who
knows what he's gonna do but his only
sustainable avenues MMA yeah meaning
once again in boxing let's say he fights
Manny Pacquiao let's say he lose are you
mistake let's say he loses that fight
right people in retired of spending
seventy bucks on a pay-per-view to watch
him take on a great guy and fall he
fights
Tony Ferguson in a unification fight in
chaos Tony Ferguson then then fight
Manny Pacquiao all day long exactly it's
it's MMA that sustains him madami Tony
it's just that for instance a
possibility for argument's sake yes I'm
taking the devil's advocate position
Tony tony got mad at me wearing the Hat
what are you changing your 10th planet
gear bro what were you wearing I don't
know how to say it pappu Co oh that
firfer that come on it's a gift it's a
gift to wear that and and listen just
because he's got a problem
Tony but I also love kabhi kabhi was a
bad [ __ ] who did not to deny
that